hey youtubers is Charlie so the really
good news is that Robert Downey jr. has
been confirmed for spider-man homecoming
so I'm gonna talk a little bit about how
he might fit into that film especially
considering that Marissa Tomei is
playing Aunt May I haven't had the
chance to see a Civil War yet so I don't
know if Marissa Tomei is in that but the
funny thing about Robert Downey jr. and
her is that they started a movie
together in the early 90s called only
you you don't need to watch it or
anything it's just a romantic comedy
starring those two characters but I like
the idea that Tony Stark is gonna be
like the cool uncle Ben proxy that just
hits on Aunt May shamelessly all the
time in that 90s movie that they starred
in together it was actually the other
way around Marissa Tomei is character
goes after Robert Downey jr. but because
it's the first spider-man film in a new
trilogy I don't know if they would share
any scenes together if Marissa Tomei and
Robert Downey jr. would be on screen
together because it would imply that
Aunt May knows that Peter Parker is
spider-man
and if you remember way back to the
Tobey Maguire spider-man trilogy on may
didn't learn his secret till way later
but they might change that for the new
spider-man trilogy because they're not
gonna do the origin story he's already
gonna be spider-man when we meet him so
they're gonna skip over a lot of that
stuff and I really like the idea that
Iron Man is going to adopt so to speak
Tony Stark is going to adopt Peter
Parker as the son that he never had
because the closest thing he has to
children right now at least that he
knows about he might have some mystery
children floating around the world
somewhere is Ultron and vision you can
kind of see how Tony Stark has visual
parody with Aunt May meaning that he's
right about that age to be a father
figure and we got to talk about Aunt May
there's been a lot of jokes going around
about the hotting of Aunt May
because you start with this version of
ought May then you get a little bit
younger with Sally Field and now we have
Marisa Tomei which to be fair is
actually a little bit more realistic
given the circumstances because even
though in the comics she's always been
portrayed as this white hair gentle
grandma figure she is the sister-in-law
of Peter's father meaning that if Peters
a teenager she'd be like in her mid-40s
which actually looks about right like
you look at Robert Downey jr. look at
Marissa Tomei they're about the average
age Peters parents would be they
wouldn't look like grandparents but
that's not the way that Stanley drew it
originally so when they did the first
spider-man trilogy they were going with
a more strict version of the comic book
version of Aunt May this version of
Peter this version of Aunt May just aged
down a little bit so they might be able
to have a little bit of fun that they
wouldn't bother
wise had so I'm actually hoping that
they play with a little bit and give
Tony Stark some scenes without mate just
so they can have a little bit of fun but
just to be clear Robert Downey's juniors
involvement in spider-man homecoming is
going to be really small to cameo level
like he'll help Peter with a problem
he'll be like an adviser character like
I said Tony Stark probably going to be
thinking of Peter Parker as the son that
he never had so he wants to help him out
but he's not gonna overpower the movie
this is largely going to be a spider-man
story about his universe of characters
that also just happens to be connected
to all the Marvel movies so maybe some
suit upgrades maybe some moral advice
although Tony Stark isn't one to be
giving moral advice especially given
what's probably going to be happening
during Civil War but in the comics they
actually have a really long history
spider-man goes way way back to the
classic Avengers comics the first
spider-man Avengers team-up was way back
in 1964 came the conquer actually sent a
spider-man robot back in time and they
had to team up to defeat it so yay for
Stan Lee spider-man robots all over the
place
I know everybody's wondering when he's
officially gonna join the Avengers
probably gonna be infinity war that's
also probably when he's gonna get the
iron spider suit because the Russos did
say that when spider-man shows up in
infinity war he'll get a new suit they
didn't specify because the movie is so
far off they probably haven't figured it
out yet but I'm guessing it's gonna be a
version of the iron spider suit the very
first time though that they offered him
membership in the Avengers was in 1966
amazing spider-man annual three so he
goes way way back with the Avengers
what about infinity war though if
spider-man's gonna team up
Thanos gonna get the Infinity Gauntlet
there's a really cool story that
Spiderman was involved in with a knows
in 1977 it was called Marvel two-in-one
annual so you might have to dig through
Marvel unlimited to find it but
spider-man flies into space with the
thing to free the Avengers which have
been locked in stasis by Thanos Adam
warlock gets freed from the soul gem
craps Thanos if you remember Marvel's
infinity storyline with Fame Thanos his
son who trapped him in a living death
it's kind of a version of that there's
actually this storyline that Spiderman
was involved in with the Avengers that
actually involves some of the stuff
that's happening in the civil war
trailer so there's this secret prison
called the raft which looks just like
this in the civil war trailer secret
prison way out in the middle of nowhere
the ocean naturally as you'd expect
there's a big prison break spider-man
gets invited to tag along after which
they offer him membership in the
Avengers that was in 2004 much much
later during civil war in the comics
he's actually been fully on the Avengers
for a while he's really close with Tony
Stark who develops the iron spider suit
for him I know we're all crossing our
fingers that the movies do iron spider
at some point but in the comics
spider-man ends up switching sides from
Team Iron Man to teen cap
so naturally he and Iron Man start going
at it Iron Man overrides his iron spider
suit because he developed it so Spider
Man goes back to his classic costume but
you have to remember that the movie
isn't doing comic book Civil War there's
gonna be a lot of familiar visual things
but they changed a whole bunch of stuff
for the story of the movie so you can
kind of see why Marvel went after
spider-man so hard like they wanted to
be able to use him in the movie so much
because he's been working with the
Avengers for so long in the comics all
we got to do now is rally Foxx so we can
get Wolverine in the Avengers they're
not really expecting that to happen
anytime soon but let me know in the
comments how do you want them to use
Tony Stark in the spider-man movies you
have to remember that a lot of it
depends on who's name is in the title of
the movie so any movie with the title
spider-man in it is gonna be way more
about spider-man that it is about Iron
Man but when you're in a Marvel movie
like The Avengers Iron Man is always
gonna be a much bigger character but I
am kind of expecting Tony Stark to fill
that Uncle Ben hole that's been left in
Peters heart because Peter Parker is a
scientist I don't know that I would say
he's a genius on the level of Iron Man
but if you've been reading the
spider-man in the Iron Man comics since
Secret Wars like in the last year or so
they've actually changed a lot about the
way spider-man works now he has Parker
Industries he's actually written a lot
more like Tony Stark has been written
and been Dez who has been writing the
new Iron Man comic has taken away most
of Tony Stark's money so it's almost
like comic book Spider Man and comic
book Iron Man have traded places and
even funnier I know everybody's asking
about mary jane and gwen stacy showing
up in the new spider-man movies mary
jane in the comics is kind of like the
new Pepper Potts
she's Iron Man's assistant he just hired
her to follow him around as the new
Pepper Potts is really funny so what's
gonna happen next this is I'm working on
a zoom hunter zolomon Flash explainer
video because there were a lot of
questions after that flash episode this
week there were a lot of big reveals
totally gonna do video tonight just
explaining what the hell is going on
with that so be sure to subscribe to get
it and I'll be doing a Doctor Strange
video in the next couple days - if
there's any other Marvel or spider-man
videos that you guys want me to do just
let me know in the comments I felt like
today was a good day to start off with
some good news just because everyone's
so sad about Prince but while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my baron zemo Captain
America Civil War teaser and you can
click here to learn more about the
spider-man homecoming movie thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you